obviously I put along my my numberphile
playing cards all their playing cards
are available for these are the best
ones
okay so just well you know you know I
know without playing cuz there's me
always a tough with a Pat Brady there is
there is you of course there they can
watch they're just here to watch I'm
also going to like Matt watch because
Matt is the is this of king of
numberphile card tricks right so okay so
I've just taken nine cards okay the
first all the clubs basically all the
numbered clubs here's the challenge to
you Brady I want you to put them in any
order you like I'm not even going to pay
attention let's go yeah okay so we read
off what number that's going to be 945
million one hundred and thirty six
thousand eight hundred and seventy two
do you know it something about that
numbers I don't think you do you notice
about it it's even it is even yeah do
you think it's so obviously not prime
then do you think which numbers in the 9
times table probably not don't feel like
it is
yeah I've been one in nine numbers is in
the 9 times table right so it's you
might think it's unlikely should we
should we have a bet okay I'll bet you a
pint right there you're saying it's not
I'm gonna say is okay so should we check
yeah okay let's check right so okay so
we put the number in divide it by nine
see if we get a whole number
oh yes we do okay now do you want to go
again don't try it again you can even
take it you can take a number out of you
on any you take any number right let's
take a little quit right okay you take
out some number so you've been left with
this number yeah okay true recognition
you can make you want to move them
around a bit
yeah let's swap the fire than the four
there we go sure you done yeah okay do
you think this is in the ninth hole
table okay well you might have wood your
bet now okay let's let's check it /
let's see known equals yes it is well
done
well you removed the nine which made it
a lot easier for me and if you'd removed
say let's put this back if you removed
the five my next step was going to be oh
I you know it's it's only fair I get to
move on out take one out as well and I
was going to take out the four
we'll come back to why that that works
later I try another trick okay
slightly different one they've got the
first four cards now multiples of three
are quite common right everyone in three
numbers is a multiple of three right
after your new four cards right you can
put them in any order just just make me
a multiple of three well you just try it
you can guess all right let's go with
two one four three okay
you don't sound confident Brady I like
to save it confidence okay 2 2 1 4 3
we're divided by 3 oh dear all right you
need some help I can I could help you
yeah I'll just I'll just gonna put one
card in card in for you right this one I
know you can put it whatever you like
now let's put it in the middle okay
let's put it in the middle right you
want to put it right in the middle you
sure you don't to put over here no I'm
gonna put in the middle okay all right
well there was tennis card over okay now
let's see if this helps the situation
okay let's try it now 2 1 5 4 3 let's
try dividing that by 3 it worked okay so
what is going on Brady what is going on
well these little tricks and well
they're kind of inspired by actually my
own incompetence and because in our last
video that you and I did together which
was about Bell figures prime if you
remember we asked the following question
we asked is this number we had a 1 and
then lots of zeros and then has 6 1 6
and then another bunch of zeros and then
a 1 we asked if this number was a prime
number or not we said it you know if we
put in enough zeros can we can we find a
prime number
and I ran a little computer code and
caught up to a hundred thousand zeros
and didn't find any attend if you
remember this and I saved up to
anything's 100,000 and the new programs
and of course our super smart
numberphile viewers immediately saw that
this was never going to be a prime
number and the reason was well if you
calculate the sum of all the digits okay
so the cross song of this object then
you'll get 1 plus lots of zeros 4 6 plus
1 plus 6
bunch of zeros again plus one and that
totals 15 now 15 is divisible by 3 and
if that number if the cross sum is
divisible by 3 then it guarantees that
the original number is divisible by 3 so
you were you were running this code
checking every number when you were
never I was never gonna be that it was
never gonna be there so wasted ways to
compute the time braids how it should
have just been as smart as numberphile
viewers right I just I just to be honest
if I'm honest I was trying to loads of
different things because I wanted
something that might sort of look cool
in the video and I got so sort of you
know sort of hung up on all different
things I was trying I sort of lost sight
of as the beauty of maths so of course
this explains what went wrong with the
with the air with your your attempt at
the number L yeah right okay you took
the first four numbers whatever no
combination you take these in I mean
these numbers 1 2 3 & 4 they add up to
10 so whatever order I put them in the
cross Sun is always going to be 10 but
10 is not divisible by 3 so whatever
number I create cannot be divisible by 3
and now I add the 5 and it doesn't
matter where I put it
the cross sum is now guaranteed to be 15
whatever number I create is guaranteed
to be divisible by 3 okay if the cross
sum is divisible by 3 the number is
divisible by 3 okay it's also true for
nines if the cross sum is divisible by 9
the number is divisible by 9 and that
comes back to this one first nine
numbers what do they Santi they sum to
45 45 is divisible by 9 so whatever
combination of these numbers I take
whatever order I take it's guaranteed to
be divisible by 9 this isn't true for
other Cross sums like if the cross sum
is divisible by 4 no it doesn't mean the
number no no that's just 3 3 & 9 it
works for okay it works for 3 & 9 okay
there are all this other rules that you
can apply to other numbers and we'll get
into that but for this this cross sum
rule it works for threes and nines let's
see if then okay let's see the proof
let's write down the kind of number that
we might be interested in let's just
write it down as follows so the number n
let's just write this and
it's gonna be an M plus one digit number
okay which we might write like this okay
so we've got a zero in the ones a 1 in
the tens and so on let's actually write
down what this number is sort of
algebraically so what this means that n
is really 10 to the N times a n plus 10
to the n minus 1 times n minus 1 plus 10
a 1 plus a 0 okay so that's what this
number is
okay any number in principle at this
stage now let's write down the cross
some okay so the cross 1 is easy to
write down let's call it t R then okay
that's just going to be the sum of all
these individual positions so n plus a n
minus 1 plus a little bit to a 1 plus a
0 ok now let's do that take away that do
that we can end - tear then okay let's
see what we're gonna get so in this
position we'll get 10 to the N minus 1 n
plus 10 to the N minus 1 minus 1 a n
minus 1
you'll get similar things all along here
you'll get 10 minus 1 a 1 and then the a
zeros are canceled now look at what
you've got you've got this is 9 right
the next one in the series would be 99
this one is going to be a whole bunch of
nines this one's going to be a one more
9 it'll have another 9 there so this is
going to be all the nines all the nines
they're all going to be nines so they're
all divisible by 9 okay so I can pull
out a factor of 9 so this is always
going to be 9 times some whole number if
the cross sum is divisible by 9 this is
divisible by 9 then this better be
divisible by 9 and similarly if the
cross sum is divisible by 3 this is
definitely divisible by 3 then this
number the original number must be
divisible by 3 that's the proof dead
simple right
then easy to prove okay why does that
only work with nines and threes
precisely because the fact that you take
the fact that you take out is 9 okay
that's why so that you know basically
you can only do it for threes and nines
then so they're a bunch of these rules
some some of which are easier than
others
and we can go through them right and so
one okay
that's these pretty easy the second
something's divisible by one two is easy
it just has to be an even number three's
we've done
what about fours okay what's the
divisibility rule for four okay I'm
gonna write you down a multiple of four
one four five six three to viewers can
check if that's a multiple of four
directly we know it is how do we know it
is the way you do the four check is you
just look at the last two digits okay
and you ask yourself are the last two
digits divisible by four if they are are
that seen off so here it's 32 that's
divisible by four I don't need to worry
about the rest and it's easy to see why
because these are a hundreds thousands
tens thousands hundred is divisible by
four a thousands divisible by four and
so on all the all the higher powers of
ten are divisible by force and the only
thing you need to check out the last two
so for that are easy as well it's a
really easy test
fives pretty easy does it end in 5 or 0
6 is well there you have to do the two
tests and the three tests okay so you
check is it even and then you do your
your cross on test for threes and it has
to pass both it has to pass both yes
sevens we're gonna come back the seven
sevens 7 is a notoriously magical and
mystical number right and sevens are the
hardest of these you know of these sort
of lower numbers for doing the air
divisibility test so we'll come back to
7 layer 8 let's try eights ok so here's
an example 1 7 5 2 4 6 4 so again
viewers can check that this this is
indeed a a multiple of 8 directly how do
we check in well it's very similar to
the four tests but it comes in an extra
stage well it depends how good you
mental arithmetic is actually okay so
what you do is so whereas with fours we
check the last two digits with 8 we
check the last three digits okay so we
look at this 4 6 4 and we ask is that
guy divisible by 8
if that guy's divisible by 8 then this
guy's guaranteed to be divisible by 8
again why does it works very similar
reason to the N to the fours so
basically because the thousands the 10
thousands and so on and all the higher
powers of 10 are automatically divisible
by 8 so you don't need to look at the
last three but then about you Brady but
my mental arithmetic is not good enough
to check of straight away whether that
number is divisible by 8 but there is a
test for checking very easily but if
you've got a three-digit number whether
it's divisible by 8 let's take this case
4 6-4
what we do is we take these two digits
here okay 46 and we multiply that by 2
and then we add the other digit okay if
you do that you get 96 now my men
arithmetic is just about good enough to
know that that is a multiple of 8 okay
so if this number is a multiple of 8
then this number is a multiple of 8 and
by association so is this number so it's
a two-stage test so let's just prove
this three-digit test for the multiples
of 8 is again quite easy so we just take
N and the number that we're interested
in well let's write it is a hundred
times 82 plus 10 times 81 plus a 0 the
test we're going to perform is let's
call it TN is basically we take you know
the first two digits so that's like 10 a
2 plus a 1 okay and we multiply that by
2 and then we add the other one which is
a 0 now take these two away from one
another then you get n minus TN what are
you gonna get you're gonna get 100 minus
20 a 2's that's 80 a 2 you get 10 minus
2 a 1 that's 8 a 1 and the a zeros
cancel you can probably see it now right
basically if this number is divisible by
8 which is the thing that was the thing
that was our test so if the test number
is divisible by 8 this is guaranteed to
be divisible by 8 then that's gonna be
divisible late
that's why works should we carry on all
right okay what we don't know is already
so
tens I think you know motives can work
out tens living as we do in our in our
base-10 world so let's do the test for
11s dead simple really easy test okay
so let's pick a number this you can
check if you use your calculator this is
a multiple of 11 okay so let's do the
test okay so the first thing you do when
you do the Elevens test is you have to
reverse the number okay so you reverse
the order of the number so you write it
as nine six six five two oh five and now
you don't take the cross some of this
number you take the alternating cross
what do I mean by that well that means I
do nine minus six plus six minus five
plus two minus zero plus five then I
think it is summer look I think it's 11
okay so again the rule is if the number
you end up with here is a multiple of 11
then the number you started out with is
a multiple of 11 so if it have been 22
or we got 22 yeah that would have
guaranteed the original number is a
multiple of 11 gosh that's really
obscure yeah we can prove it if you want
that's quite quite easy to prove but
there's another sort of flight sort of
take on the card trick that you can do
for this one it needs you to be slightly
quick with your with your mental
arithmetic so basically you lay out a
bunch of cards I don't know any other
let's let's not worry too much about
what it is okay and let's take five a
five digit number okay so you want to
start off with something that's not
going to be a multiple of 11 curious
check whether this one is or isn't it
before we proceed any way ahead of that
no it's not good just played our random
number here okay and now you're gonna
show how clever you are by you're just
gonna say I'm gonna add one card and
make it a multiple of 11 okay so how do
you do that I can't do that thing in my
head reversing and alternating across
some okay let's see if I can do it okay
so it's you have to do it yes you have
to think the answer in your head
okay so I'm gonna
you
yes okay right yes I know how do you
thought okay I need another card yeah
okay so I need to uh huh okay I think
that should do it
yeah so if you've got much fewer mental
arithmetic it's bad man you'll do this
in no time so you were reversing that
number then alternate yeah so I was
adding I was I was doing the cross one
at the alternating cross I'm in Reverse
right five minus three plus one minus
two plus four I think is five okay so I
need to take off that that would get me
to zero which is definitely a multiple
of 11 using the goal is to get so
multiple of 11 you can also start
playing around putting numbers at the
start but it gets a bit more complicated
but all right let's try it okay 5 4 2 1
3 5 / 11 yay okay so obviously you need
to be pretty sharp limit or if it's sick
to do this one which I'm afraid I'm not
twelves twelves wells Wells is just you
build it from the fours and threes okay
so it's the same as he just you do the
four tests and then you do the the three
tests so that's easy and that just has
to pass by faster pass based yeah yeah
we could go on and but let's come back
to sevens okay cuz we skip sevens which
is a bit naughty sevens are hard sevens
are notoriously hard
[Music]
there is a reasonably simple one
but it also reminds me a friend of mine
I got a friend called nori nori is a lot
of things but he is not a mathematician
but he has this this thing he can do
where he if he sees a number he can tell
immediately whether it's a multiple of
seven and it's really strange he's sort
of like he sort of season number in a
cloud in his mind and then if he's sort
of warm towards it if he feels like a
friendship towards he then that means
it's a multiple of seven this is totally
real
just totally he's not as I said he's not
a mathematician he did English at uni
but yet he has this rather unusual thing
that he has how did you find out that he
has this ability how does that come up
in conversation I know he likes to talk
about himself a lot who's always got a
coffee at some point do you test him do
you can do it there's no known lesson
about you can totally do yeah so you can
go to about five digits and then he
starts to feel physical effects
apparently at that point video with nori
well the irony was he was but I told her
I thought I mentioned this he he decided
that a whole video should be about him
this is typical nori but I said the
whole video is not going to be about you
know but maybe it is hey let us have a
picture of him to put on the screen no
he will love to have a picture of
himself on the screen okay so how do I
do okay so we got a multiple of seven
let me write it down I know he looked at
that number he'd start to seal his
friendship feelings of warmth and all
that right okay so the seventh test the
simplest one I could find is the
following
you take the blocks of three okay so
this block of three here nine eight four
and then we do like an alternating sum
again so we don't take the next block of
three which is this one we take it away
nine seven six and then we add we keep
going like this the next block is going
to be a six of course we stop here okay
if we had more we'd keep doing this in
an in an alternating way okay so now you
actually calculate this thing and which
is obviously pretty easy to do so that
is going to be I think 14 so if the
result is a multiple of seven that
guarantees that the original number is a
multiple of seven I imagine quite often
we're going to get negative numbers on
this
this test that's fine that they can be
negative numbers it can be a multiple of
seven it's just a and negative number x
times something this was actually a
really really simple example and it was
pure luck that it turned out to be so
simple normally you're going to end up
with a three-digit number here right so
you're faced with the question of is
that three-digit number a multiple of
seven which generally is not gonna be
that easy and so let's do another
example maybe quickly just to see how
that can arise here I have another
little number which happens to be a
multiple of seven so I do one two three
- eight seven - and I am gonna get this
it turns out to be minus seven four nine
that's be hard isn't it Brady that's
beyond my mental arithmetic that's for
sure okay so we're going to now do
another three three digit test on sevens
is that really but I mean seven four
nine actually is pretty easy that's
really easy this is the bell finger
probe okay okay but let's pretend it's
hard but what would be the test that we
do okay so you take your seven we don't
need to worry about a minus so you take
your seven forty-nine okay so we take
this number here which is 74 and we take
off twice this number here okay so two
times nine
okay that's 56 and then the issue is is
this a multiple of seven which of course
it is okay that would guarantee that
this is and by association this is this
this test for three digits it's quite
straightforward to prove proving that
these blocks of three works is it's not
so easy you can prove it okay you can't
prove it and it relies on two facts
we're not going to do the proof the
first fact that you need to prove this
is that this number is basically seven
times 11 times their team okay so
actually what's the point about is that
it's a multiple of seven the other fact
that you need to know is that imagine
99999 is also a multiple of certain and
it's this multiple of seven so this is a
multiple of seven this is a multiple of
seven these are the two facts you need
to prove this set particular sevens test
but it's quite an elaborate
it's yeah it's it's it's it's yeah
exactly it's it's it's not it's not
particularly entertaining proof notice
by the way that's got this number in
here do you remember that number I do
isn't that the one where you can like
cycle yeah yeah yeah we did we did a
video on that number fact I think we
even probably showed that result I'm
quite it sort of pleased me that that
reappeared okay okay so there is you can
do one in all generality okay and which
I don't know how exciting this is but we
can do it with an example
any number ends in one three seven or
nine you know you might need to use a
few iterations of it to actually get get
down to the to the bottom but yeah there
is a general test so let's let's do an
example okay so I can illustrate the
general test another piece of paper and
yeah why not
so let's try it for 23 okay so the first
thing that you have to do is let's start
with 23 this we're gonna look at we want
to ask things in a 23 times table we're
never we're gonna test for is this
number which is in the 23 times table so
the test goes in various stages first
thing you've got to do is you've got to
generate a new number from this guy okay
I'm gonna call it the divvy number okay
from 23 from 23 I'm going to generate 23
divvy number so the first thing you have
to do is you have to multiply this by
something to make it end in nine okay so
if you've got a number ending in three
to make it end in a nine you just
multiply it by three okay so that will
give us 69 so you can now got a number
that ends in a nine okay if you had if
your number ended in a one or a seven or
a nine
so it wasn't 23 it was twenty-one or 27
or 29 you would multiply by a different
number to get it to end in a nine okay
it would still be one of one three seven
and nine but you just use something else
the goal is to get something to ends and
I know okay once you've got some of the
ends and a nine you then add one okay so
that's easy that gives us something
that's a multiple of ten it's guaranteed
to be a multiple of ten okay in our case
it's 70 now once you've got this
multiple of ten you just divide by ten
okay so let's divide this by 10 and we
obviously get seven
okay this is our divvy number so what's
the test okay so now we've got our divvy
number we've got our number that we're
interested in looking at and so the
thing you have to do is you have to
write this number in the form 10 T plus
Q now that if I do that that means that
T is 103 and Q is 5 now using your Divya
number what you do is you create so
let's call the divvy number M okay it
creates a new number which is this thing
okay so let's calculate what this is
okay so M is 7 Q is 5 and this is 103
that happens to be 138 which hopefully
you mentally over to rithmetic is good
enough to check with that that see that
that is a multiple of 23 so if the
number you end up with here is a
multiple of the 23 then the number you
are testing is a multiple of 23 so you
can adapt this method to any number that
ends in 1 3 7 or 9 and it will work ok
what it relies on is that the numbers
constructed in this way it's guaranteed
that if something divides this number
then it it will also divide this number
okay and you can easily prove that not
too difficult to prove okay not the
easiest process to run through but no
it's not but then it's applying to any
number but this is this is completely
general thing now it doesn't apply to
numbers divisible by 5 it almost applies
to all the odd numbers but the idea is
that the goal is the challenge of course
is to get you've got to get it's very
important that you get to this point
where you have a something that ends in
a 9 that's what you need and then so you
do this add one business blah blah blah
right so that's that's important as
course that works with the 1 threes 7s
and nines that you can do that for do
you like that it's general it's not
particularly I mean come on how good
yield 33,000 table Brady exactly but do
you look at that and think oh that's a
cute trick or do you think y'all that
was bit of a mess if you want to know
what I like about it is so when I found
out about it a sort of immediately
wanted to prove it
okay I wanted to see why it works that's
what that's what I think that's true of
anybody who's so into math is okay it
works why does it work let's prove it
you immediately sit down and prove it to
yourself and you and you understand why
it works and I think that's where what I
liked when I saw why it worked which is
in the proof so I think we should leave
the viewers to prove it right here we go
how many numbers below 200 have exactly
three divisors for example 4 has 1 2 & 4
itself but how many more might exist
this is a new problem from brilliant
today's episode sponsor for a while I've
been talking about brilliants problems
of the week but I'm excited to see they
now have daily problems I also like this
one about chess bores and dominoes of
course brilliant still has all their
top-end courses and quizzes spanning all
sorts of mathematical and science topics
and they're still offering 20% off a
premium subscription to numberphile
viewers simply go to brilliant org slash
numberphile to check it out there's
plenty of free stuff on the site but a
premium subscription might be worth a
look
and after today's video I hope you might
do well with questions like these ones
our thanks to brilliant go to brilliant
door org slash numberphile for more
information
god worst contry go well if you've got
patient audience you guys do this